well you see I've always maintained the
mixed challenge for my generation would
be how we cope with the end you're
inclined to go from that to a situation
where the wall comes down we're nearly
25 and stops that is I was always said
the most important event in my life and
I want wanted to dedicate my
professional life manage consequences to
make sure that we could handle that we
can integrate some essentially senior
engineering project that we could offer
the people they are wanted freedom
openness transparency all the things
that have lacked during communist or
prep repression and i think frankly
looking back now with all the mistakes
that were made and other problems that
rose it is a sec tabulous this
spectacular success of historic
proportions and i believe should be
careful that that we are is your penis
and for me interesting the biggest
change me one step to to challenge the
premise that Europe needs to be
constructed at the expense of the nation
state that we can only do the European
things by taking them away from the
nation-state I mean that crisis wrong I
think Europe all you need constructed
with the nation-states nation-states
usually reinvigorate their sovereignty
needs to be reinvented and recharged as
a word through Europe
I that believed me in the idea of season
coming up I thought it was a political
game my I thought it would bring
anything I thought the end of the day in
the european council will decide anybody
cry while it was I wrong who's wrong on
this massively more the fact that they
chose Ashley gave jean-claude juncker a
position that is more independent from
national governments from the European
Council that any of his predecessors
before so political Commission means the
president the Commission who has the
room to be more political than his
predecessors because he could say no to
big member states with measure course
but still too much larger degree than
his predecessors because he got his
mandate in the courts with here in
parlance and of course you know the
european council endorses but it wasn't
a choice that has a huge little effect
on the relationship between the
institutions and so the Commission is
now thanks to John little girl in a
position to be more independent and when
he says its last chance Commission it is
a commission that is more independent
and therefore trying to be the
Commission as the tech missile treaty
which is to be normal secretary-general
of the European Council neither the
slave to the european plug so we need to
ascertain our old position and need to
say no sometimes it again say no to the
European Parliament give you
chris said no all but abusive that
anymore so both human cuts and dirty
part have to get used to as do Road
Commission attracted efficient service
users that role and I see it as my duty
to to sort of help commission structure
is get your spectral because no
Commission is traditionally and has
become ugly is no more a huge collection
of silence silos that shall meet and do
the business with an asylum and with a
new structure with vice presidents you
know we're breaking down side and that
is creating much more political momentum
at a much earlier stage we discuss
policy across different policy areas at
a much earlier stage than is to be done
before a mass creates this momentum as
well
to paraphrase Mark Twain announcement
about my knees is a bit premature Europe
has a lot to offer to the world we have
I think highest educated population
across the floor and out of the world we
have the strongest the best social
systems of the world we have the
filthiest best educated and youngest
generation of the world there are many
things going for us but we got to see a
man we think we're in a sort of end of
days which i think is totally
unjustified I'm happy to change up my
speeches great features that will not
change and where we are taking down
silos in the Commission I see a European
society silos emerging all over the
place in society I get a very aggressive
example my oldest daughter just 28 she
is a pharmacist assistant my older son
he's 26 he's a lawyer they lived in
different worlds littering
difficult they were worried about
different things my son where is our
global problems might also we're
establishing read/write head and this is
the same generation two people love each
other tle would do anything for each
other but sometimes alternate understand
each other exploded this is happening in
young generations or west grow
especially in Europe don't they don't
share get together it grosses we're all
on the same but this is at least as many
people out there who don't understand
that commitment to the rest of all
because they have different workers and
that's where my where I believe we're
social democracy I can input is dying it
because we're no longer building bridges
we're returning to a situation where
politics will be formulated as politics
serving wine specific interest and that
how you do that in complex democratic
society I don't see I don't see it
working so we need to get together with
people in social networks with people in
in civil society to make sure that we
start developing the concept of building
bridges between people with different
interests and creative coalition it's
based on shared interest whereas shared
interest in a society where is it can we
formulate it across social boundaries
across ethnic boundaries across age
boundaries can we formulate something
that we have in common that is where the
future lies
politics I'm not sure where well
equipped to get what we need
since borders between nation states in
Europe unknown resource of frets
the necessity for nation-states to
repress diversity within their borders
as large image so nation-states because
of European integration become extremely
relaxed about cultural differences
within the boards the Dutch language was
suppressed generations in the North
France because France saw it as a threat
to its territorial integrity now Dutch
language is flourishing in his lower jaw
to the north trans people think that is
very interesting say half of the German
denisa France say happen to original
languages in many many nations and so I
would see the pro process of
regionalization as a product of European
integration it's not a contradiction
with European integration into your
appearance graceless to take that
problem way leads to new problem which
is the strike striving for independence
regions to see the belgian city in the
united kingdom is using it in spain and
interestingly enough all these
sub-national entities regional entities
have one desiring come to be a
full-fledged member / european project
they are extremely fabulous because
the European Union is the answer for
them to what they perceive as the rest
of the nation state
but the answer is not a place for
rhetoric the biggest thing you could do
populist politicians is to answer that
populism with your populism it only
increases the sports they can create
folder option so we have legal
instruments to be very precise to
analyze laws of proposition we're really
get into the heart of the matter and are
very precise on the legal instruments we
can correct that every time they will
give in to us every time until now once
we say no here you'll be cross the line
you shouldn't do is it comeback having
said that is one thing we cannot really
do anything about it members day it's
not willing to address that amongst
themselves
just one example the refugee crisis we
are facing all the proposals that were
agreed our commission
all the proposals challenger also
commissioned roses of the we took a huge
risk we didn't go to my mistakes let us
understand okay no we took the step the
distribution key with something member
states some mistakes it's like that we
made an analysis of how would you solve
this issue one member state saying you
take care of your problems i go to look
away as they do going on for years how
do you get out of that situation we
thought about it long and hard the only
concrete response to that would be show
solidarity and the only way of doing
that is in crisis situations have a
distribution key so that people you know
better brought together solidarity
quality of the our proposals the
diplomacy we pry in talking to many
states about this the balance we see
between the different interest because
the ones had an interest in not being
left with all the refugees only in their
country and the other side an interest
in making sure that the countries were
people arriving by the rules which have
been doing for a long time create a
balance and though their proposals to
achieve both cause and it might work so
now we're now in the best position on
that then we were before but make no
mistake this problem will not go away
will be a long-term issue for Europe and
Europe to understand that it is no rule
of them a continent of origin but it's
becoming a content
of destination like narrow States and
others that psychological change this
past was the biggest challenge we face
first of all be fine about the
complexity of the problem is people
accept your families people are a
loosely fed up with simplistic solutions
but we're in a situation where my
complex answer if it is not believe it
doesn't have any perspective and the
simplistic solution many people say okay
the complex answer is not working who
knows it simplistic one might let's
follow that partition that's the
situation we're in that's why the
extreme rights on the rise in tirupur
mini nation so all the issues you've met
energy refugees unemployment the problem
is a lack of perspective what is the
point we're heading to and how do you
communicate that by not treating people
like simpletons the temptation of
politics for too long not as willing to
make things not just uncomplicated in
language but simple in contact that is
wrong your language has to be
but if you try and convince people that
there are simple solutions to complex
problems you're in the middle of the
mine field of poppies
many things they want I want Christmas
we want Europe to concentrate on the
issues we want less red tape horse for
me to size and devices we want to make
sure that the internal market obviously
better we want to have the opportunity
we want energy Union the United Kingdom
wants all of that so we can work out and
of course there are changes they wanted
a treaty will listen to them we'll try
and advise them to do not I will try and
find a constitution at the end of the
day David Cameron will have to make up
his mind whether what you can reverse it
aggressively this collington with us is
something he wants to take to the bridge
with a clear position that they should
stay in the European but subtitle rich
people is the manor two referendums not
sat on bushwick to the side and we will
abide by resulting will try and advise
wearing hash from the position for my
personal position that I believe this
absolutely users
or I'm even so I have American to save
minutes later the UK suppose to say in
the EU